Satan de Maurice piada Palme d'Or très
contesté à Cann et puis pris de la mise
en scène pour vim Venders c'est pris de
l'interprétation masculine pour Marcelo
maestroyani dans quelques minutes en
direct de Cann avec Bernard rap Jacques
Chirac proscrit toute exclusion ou rejet
en évoquant avec son gouvernement la
polémique sur les rapprochements entre
sa majorité et le Front National à
Bruxelles 15000 agriculteurs de toute
l'Europe manifeste alors que les
ministres de la communauté tentent de
fixer les prix agricoles pour la saison
8788 aujourd'hui mardi 19 mai 1987
nouvelle journée de détention pour les
otages français au Liban Marcel fontaine
et Marcel carton Jean-Paul Koffman et
Jean-Louis dormandin d'Antenne 2 n'ont
toujours pas été
libérés bonsoir monsieur le Président
montant Bernard rap c'est à vous pour ce
40e palmarès du festival de can bonsoir
Claude et bien ici c'est un petit peu la
folie je peux vous le dire ce soir des
des mitraillage de toute part des
photographes des télévisions et
j'aperçois Yve montant et Maurice piala
donc Yve montant le prix président du
jury Maurice piala Palme d'Or
aujourd'hui qui me rejoignent sur ce
studio alors venez vous asseoir
messieurs marcialo Mastriani également
qui a sa place sur ce plateau prenez
place voilà mettez-vous là prenez place
mettez-vous à gauche marcho asseyez-vous
vous êtes devant la caméra voilà c'est
un peu la folie je vous le disais mais
ça va très vite ah ça YZ maro venez sur
ma droite je un petit peu de silence si
c'est possible voilà pendant que mes
invités s'instent je vous rappelle
rapidement quand même les grands moments
de ce palmarès donc mauce piala qui a
donc la Palme d'Or Grand Prix spécial du
juré l'inanimité pour repentir du du
soviétique abouadé il y a beaucoup de
bruit mais c'est ainsi ce soir prix du
40e anniversaire pour Federic Fellini
pour l'INT Vista prix interprétation
masculine donc pour Marcello mastroyani
prix interprétation féminine pour
Barbara herchet pour son rôle dans le
film de Konchalovski pris de la mise en
scène pour vim Venders pour les Ailes du
désir et puis le Prix du Jury bien qui
est partagé entre Souleiman fisté et
pour la lumière et pour
le film japonais je crois qu'on a dit
l'essentiel onendra plus dans le détail
de palmar tout à l'heure mes invités
sont installés voilà les ver circul ma
tour d'abord vers vous parce que c'est
c'est le grand prix de la soirée un prix
qui é diversement accueilli pour ceux
qui n'ont pas qui l'ont pas vu il y a
quelques minutes propose redécouvrir
donc ce moment un peu spécial du
festival on annonçait donc que c'était
Mace pi pour le soleil de Satan qui
venait de se voir décner par le jury la
Palme d'Or c'était il y a quelques
minutes
et vous regardez avec
nous
l'unanimité à Maurice piala pour sous le
soleil de
[Applaudissements]
Satan
oui oui c'est beaucoup plus facile pour
moi de prendre la parole parce que je
suis indirectement concerné
je voudrais je voudrais je voudrais vous
demander d'écouter Maurice pial parce
que moi j'ai toujours été très frappé
par
l'intelligence et la l'amour du cinéma
qu'il a même si son film est très
controversé ce soir je vous demande de
laisser parler je vous le dis je trouve
qu'il parle toujours merveilleusement
bien de ce qu'il fait et même si on n
pas d'accord laissez-lui une chance ce
soir
merci
voilà Maurice pial on on va voir Maurice
piala et Gérard Mace c'était pas facile
il y a quelques minutes pour
vous oh non
moi je suis assez Cabo alors ouais j'ai
pas beaucoup de j'ai assez de s fr c'est
pas je je le constate comme ça ce que je
tiens à dire tout de suite je parlerai
pas beaucoup plus j'ai que trop parlé P
un festival c'est que ça m'a beaucoup
appris ce festival alors qu'on dit
toujours truc quoi ah ben l'accueil que
le film a reçu et surtout quand j'ai vu
après j'aiété chez mon oncle Bandole
puis j'ai regardé hier après-midi les
émissions sauf la vôtre d'ailleurs et et
et et je me suis rendu compte qu'il y
avait un danger qu'il fallait pas être
comme ça qu'il fallait être plus modeste
et plus simple et que quand je vois tous
les gens qui sont venus ce soir je c'est
une leçon pour moi parce que faut un
petit peu que je je mette en veilleuse
non pas que je
sois comme ça de ce que j'ai fait mais
je sais pas c'est commême quelque chose
qui remonte à la surface et et qui vaut
mieux couper dans l'uf avant que ça
prenne de qu'est-ce qu'il emporte quand
même ce soir c'est un petit peu
d'amertume dans l'accueil de vos
collègues enfinitive dans la salle ou la
joie d'avoir cette palme d'or c'est ni
amertume ni joie je je je me sens
pourtant je suis profondément français
mais je me sens pas français parce que
les Français pas ceux qui m'entourent là
pas pas ceuxl je sa pas les Français
n'aiment pas gagner j'ai gagné c'est
tout ça
suffit il mon'tend c'était donc une
palme d'or à l'unanimité vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure l' donné à l'unanimité
é parce que nous avons considéré que le
travail qu'a fait piala c'est gênant
parce qu'il mait en scène et qu'il l'
devant moi le travail qu'il a essayé de
faire et qu'il a réussi est un travail
qui met le cinéma sur un autre niveau à
une autre à un autre étage et on peut
forcément bien sûr moi-même je suis
comme ça être sensible à des films que
je dirais peut-être un peu plus
abordable peut-être un peu plus facile
mais heureusement qu'il y a des pialas
qu'il a des God a des reenis aussi pour
porter le cinéma à une autre auteur
alors je me réjouis que nous ayons voté
l'unanimité alors ce film a émergé
naturellement il y a eu un gros débat
autour non ça a été relativement assez
facilement fait
finalement deux ou trois de membres jury
ont un peu regretté que parfois il y
avait des mots qui leur échappaient
forcément bernano c'était pas c'esticile
pour nous j'imagine pour les étrangers
mais l'unanimité s'est faite vraiment
d'une façon très spontanée et ce qui
nous a vra
réjoui tous voilà très bien alors un mot
un mot de Gérard pardieu Gérard donc
vous avez le rôle principal rôle
masculin principal dans le film votre
réaction à ce qui s'est passé tout à
l'heure ah non moi je trouve que c'est
TR moi je ne sais pas c'est ce qui fait
que j'aime aussi énormément Maurice
parce que là-dessus moi j'ai une
réaction beaucoup plus j'allais
dire mais c'est pas en fait c'est
pas vrai c'est que dans un moment comme
celui-là moi je sais pas j'avais envie
de dire même j'aime tout le monde même
ceux qui me sifflent mais peut-être que
je ne suis qu'un acteur et que Maurice
est surtout un auteur du cinéma en tout
cas j'étais tellement heureux que Mar
est le prix et que Maurice est la palme
et que ce soit Yve président du du jury
cette année-là qui le donne parce que ce
qu'il a dit tout à l'heure et d'ailleurs
tous les les gens que j'aimais beaucoup
comme Monsieur CISS CISS que Monsieur
Venders parle du cinéma comme ils en ont
parlé c'est une telle chance d'avoir
d'avoir ces envies ces passions que ma
fois je pardonne tout à fait à Maurice
d'avoir lever son point en signe de
colère alors un mot rapide voulez dire
un mot non alors rapidement Mar a
beaucoup bruit pardonnez-nous je sais
pas si vous nous entendez bien il y a
beaucoup de bruit il y a beaucoup de
monde il y a des centaines de
photographes et a une rumeur importante
j'imagine chez vous chez en tout cas à
Paris Marcello donc le prix
d'interprétation c'est la deuxième fois
que vous l'obtenez la dernière fois
c'était il y a 17 ans je crois oui pour
drame de la
jalousieol oui et là vous arrivez donc
de Budapeste exprès pour ça et même
l'autre fois j'ar avec un petit avion du
nord de l'Italie c'est c'est c'est ma
c'est mon style s'il y aura une autre
fois j'irai encore avec un avion je
prends les fruit et je répare alors
c'est un très beau prix pour un rôle
magnifique dans un dans un film qui n'a
pas de récompense aujourd'hui qui est un
très grand film qui est film de
michalkov ah oui ben évidment ça m COF
ça c'est la la phrase qu'on dit toujours
mais je crois qu'au cinéma s'il n'y a
pas un grand M enin les acteurs peuvent
pas gagner de prix c'est pas le théâtre
l'acteur il est là vite lu c'est le hos
mais au cinéma il faut c'est lui qui
conduit la baraque do être formidable si
lui il est formidable peut-être que vous
pouvez gagner un prix c'est pas pour
jouer du violent mais mais le cinéma est
fait par le ma en scne n on a des
instruments intéressants conclure
d'accord j'ai fini voilà ok juste un mot
pour vous dire que Barbara nous nous a
rejoint c'est le prix d'interprétation
féminine donc pour le film de kovski
c'est pour le
film je deme si elle est contente
j'imagine qu'elle est contente oui je
suis si heureuse très
bien
tu demandes quelle est la la
signification d'un prix à can pour une
comédien américaine
aujourd'hui bien en TR mots vraiment
nous explique que pour elle c'est
important c'est réel et que c'est en
quelque sorte comme comme un rêve qui
est devenu réalité voilà je vais vous
rendre l'antenne Claude j'espère que
vous nous avez bien entendu suffisamment
entendu on se retrouvera tout à l'heure
la deè partie de ce journal avec
d'autres réactions et quelques extraits
des films merci d'être venu
immédiatement au sortir donc de cette de
l'annonce de ce palmarès merci ne bougez
pas c'est à VOUS Claude merci Bernard
merci messieur Mame